we see how do you the name Ricci my
grandmother's sister nicknamed me Ricci
to a form of my true name which is the
recently Finlay and where'd you grew up
Oakland tell me about your family I
think we love with one parent my mother
my she had my little sister she two
girls raised alone how was your
childhood my childhood was in the up and
downs you know
scurries scattered and you know I've had
a share of turmoil
I watched you know well I was molested
as a child raped as a teenager partially
Waits's in adults taking advantage of a
lot my cousin on my outside of my
grandmother's sister one of her sons
I cut them how old were you two
yes that was - I didn't know I didn't
know what was why not it was like a
tickle game so when it comes to the
average spots and person being ticklish
their tummy or underarms or behind the
calves or their feet
I'm not taking no spot but my pelvic are
you so not reasons I am kind of them I
guess them stiff when it comes to
sexually Alex she intimacy within the
male and unless I'm provoking myself any
other end bounces to come in there
repulsive to me I don't like to be
touched certain ways I don't need to be
touched at all really to me that's
painful within itself because I can't um
Express
emotion if I want to with anyone whether
it's male or female and I like embraces
no hugs right so I'm kind of stiff kind
of stiff little bold and blunt and comes
to something making me discomfort it
I am
get aggressive really quick I'm short
Tim Burton yeah I kind of like grew up
too quick too quick I had a lot of
responsibilities at a young age what age
were you
what's home I was pretty much rebellious
so I think I started him in that
limelight of a role at 13 I'm my mom she
had him her own style of marriage so I
wasn't too much um I see him governed
into where to be when to be and what to
do at certain times so I'm I ran in and
out all the time I did it how one is you
so I guess you could certainly say 13 at
least that was the last time I'm I got
an [ __ ] I did that when I ran away
and all my sisters and little cousins
play cuttings and y'all I ended up at
the mall and it was because of me
because I'm the oldest that they
followed suit
did my mom got whooping cuz I went to
school the next day with shorts on and
this teacher seen it
cause the housing um came home mom was
in there fine and then I found out later
which got him
centrally lucky I can't put my hands
ring anymore
you did that on purpose I didn't I
missed her then miss her now he left
home it
thirteen yes what did you do it thirteen
thirteen and I skipped school with the
house parties and I didn't have the eyes
from you know boys yet I didn't have
eyes for boys until I got late in my
twenties really so but I didn't lose my
virginity at 15 that wasn't well this is
kind of a go you know I was learning a
Laurie they were alluring but I really
didn't have any interest in them
but yeah I 13 I left home and started
seeking other things
I guess my thing that wasn't like the
limelight of them dealing drugs was like
and so that was like the in-crowd thing
so that's what I did at my early teenage
years try to support myself a mom we
were living in the streets and I like a
lot of things my mother had to do to
support me and my sister so I kind of
like I wanted to take some ease or
pressure off her her
so I started doing drugs
and from there my route got a little bit
more strange I did all most everything
tried jobs never had a job until I was
like 19 my own Ian's my only one job
ever had a job since I'm 43 today well
not today but answers right now I'll be
44 coming up this year six months
I haven't seen my family in over 23
years
I have a son one child
he's my only kid ever seen him since he
was two months old took from my arms Wow
this breast baby I was homeless me and
my husband
yeah I'm legally married haven't moved
my husband since 2006 we got married in
2003 after my son was born yeah I miss
him too I don't know where he is either
mark I still love you too
where do you stay now
right now I'm homeless here in LA I live
a little skid row down here on Gladys
Street near the park yeah I have my own
tent just me gotta turn well there with
the people I have to deal with get by
tired the struggle I've been struggling
too and what are you doing for money now
I do it a little bit uh everything under
design them i hustle cans and bottles
and I often them just see how I hate the
word prostitute
hey the word hoeing so I have to like I
think the word dating too so I've been
like um present myself in a straight way
not to where it's like noticeable I
don't have no front lines like hey you
want a date none that or hey can I earn
some money with you I don't have no
front lines them it's just a casual
hello if I see certain like uttering
this or certain interest then what you
really have in like initially meeting me
as in my mind but you have a meeting of
my body I can always decipher that
which sometimes it's very sickening okay
it's okay cuz nowadays nobody really
wants to meet you they just want to meet
your body I know I have i well my mom
was the first one to tell me I know I
have a alluring image that was designed
from God in the shape of me aiding to it
sometimes I wish I didn't have it a lot
of times I just look sloppy but sloppy
isn't in you because mom didn't raise me
that way
sometimes they give a sloppy outlet just
so people can stay away from me
I only bothered I kind of like being by
myself but I don't opinion by myself
without my family
so that things are long for my family a
lot of times I missed my son and my
husband
I missed my grandmother's funeral missed
a lot things sometimes I think I even
missed me
that's the status of it all when you
miss yourself then you finally realize
it that you can miss you because you
missed the elements that we're supposed
to be given to you you adapt systems
[ __ ]
that shouldn't have been the part of
your character your personality the ioan
home we can ever even know of ourselves
I sometimes look at myself as a
entrepreneur because I'm a person and I
kind of like thinks in about in and out
of the box you know they say never
supposed to have two feet in or two feet
out
I always keep letting it out because you
never know which way you gotta go can't
get up and down solve what around it all
kind of try sectors
but there's squiggly wobbly zigzags
sodomy Becca
I've had my time and I've done some
damage to people caught up with me I
swam a little bit more understanding
I used to judge her glands growing up
that's why they were doing this or why
they were doing that I understand it now
because I live it
by force it's not by choice either it's
just the way my life is good to go
who knows
it's horrific question when people say
that
because you don't even know
and they have a terrible
sir things cause you to pause stop I've
pretty much been stagnated because I go
forward but then I just stopped
stuck in the room
what is the drug you're using down here
I use crack
I used to use crack to get over the hurt
s suffered you know in nowadays I just
use crack to put up with but I think I
allow myself to go to a deport them
so smart idea yeah both breezy of
getting off the street and living a
better life
I surely do
um I kind of like noticing a lot of my
patterns detouring
a lot of people that have facility with
a lot of people that have facilitated
with and I am don't want to be bothered
with them anymore
because they mean no good to you even
though they say they are I did this for
you I did that for you
and sometimes I feel I've done more than
for them than they have for me
you know that's reality I think maybe we
both might but sometimes it's very very
aiding
nobody can ever do for you what you
don't do for yourself see I think that's
another reason why I've got allowed
myself to be stagnated I don't want no
one to ever throw something that they've
done for me out of the kindness or the
charity of their heart or the goodness
of them to turn around and toss in my
face like a pie smashed or something
I wonder why either that's me this
supposed to be from the goodness of your
heart it's not ever supposed to be
mentioned again that's the goodness of
your heart but it never needs to be
mentioned
[Music]
my scarves are so overwhelming to myself
we all have a leverage that can send
this up person this down
just like that palm go down the same
street I step in the crack I fall down a
hole we can't get out I keep going down
the same street keep getting the same
results in different aspects till I
finally decide
when I wake up the next morning - take
it - from route
I'm trying my best to take that route I
really am trying my best to take that
route but I feel for me I need my family
first
in step two my achievements
because they are my achievement
I went away to try to do good start it
off bike but I was at the hardcore do
you got scared straight though up that's
over how did that go
[Applause]
city to city stage the state so I got
stuck in that state but nowhere to go
but to poverty homelessness
like that since then yeah
so one day a church
was the owner in state I happen to be
living in forget the name of the church
but uh it's very known it was a of a
garden and Broadway somewhere over there
I only stayed three days before I came
out here didn't know my way around yeah
quickly got it after though
I wouldn't change them I wouldn't change
my steps that made me what I am or made
my mind conscious
[Music]
a my mind conscious to such poison that
lurks in any Avenue whether it's drugs
or people
we're all poisonous in some type of way
all things are poisonous in sent away
it's just how you view it how you
analyze it decipher it code it whatever
you just have to be the one
to know how you want to live
how you can do its to write by yourself
don't worry about other starts to worry
about these images they're wearing how
they get admire how they got that
success it's up to you to make your own
success
not the success in the stage that I see
out stagnated myself if he adds a small
success lab people say no who the hell
that isn't but it's a small success to
me because I realize it that it took me
a lot to get through and to this point
and I know I know
they could never know you really
wouldn't want to know
just
always cute the advice how'd you hit
smile your tears through your tears
always smile I'll do my best
cuz this helps ifs what helps me aid
through the day even when I don't want
to go through the day I don't like drama
so
I stay afloat
life only causes you
oh that you can give it
you
you